VIDEO CONTAINS SPOILERS FOR FAUN LABYRINT FILM!
I think it's okay to start analyzing the Faun's Labyrinth from Guilerme del Tora's spoiler.
Ophelia, the heroine, dies at the end.
I think it's okay to say that, because del Toro does the same in film.
The first shot of Faun's Labyrinth is at the same time the end of the film.
And that makes del Toro complicate the end.
But before we get to him, let's just say a few things about fairy tales.
For most of us, Walt Disney is a source of fairy tales.
It's no coincidence. Walt Disney was the king of fairy tales,
when he made classic fairy tales like Snow White, Cinderella or Sleeping Beauty
in a completely new way, and copyrights have emerged.
However, because the film was a relatively new medium,
taking the royal throne required Disney,
to remain true to the original versions of these stories
which was popularized by Charles Perrault and the Grimm brothers.
Switching from book to cinema made as smooth as possible
and even went so far as to start making movies by opening a book.
Disney was smart. His films are now considered classic.
And despite being true to the 19th century
he remained faithful and deepened the morality of the 19th century.
Conservative Patriarchal System of Values
in which the prince always comes to the aid of a helpless heroine.
A system of values ​​that was obsolete at that time.
In this way, Disney has limited things that are possible in fairy tales.
In Faun's Labyrinth, Guillermo del Toro tries
demolish these boundaries and do so by changing the context of these stories.
Instead of drawing from one source, del Toro draws on a large number of resources
and neither of them places more weight than the other,
leaving them to act against one another,
to create a new context.
The film tells the story of the little girl of Ophelia and her mother Karmen,
who decides to live with the high-ranking fascist Vidal
five years after the end of the Spanish Civil War.
Vidal tries to suppress the last remnants of the resistance in the mountains,
while expecting the birth of her child.
Meanwhile, Ophelia finds herself on a magical quest afterwards
what Faun tells her is the lost princess of the underground kingdom.
From there, the story unfolds in two parallel storylines.
It becomes a magical expedition and a political drama.
What is important is that neither story goes down the other.
Del Toro did this by combining these stories in a way
which makes any effort to explain them problematic.
At the end of the film, we see a seemingly hard blow to the story of Ophelia.
Vidal comes to Ophelia speaking with Faun, and when the camera approaches his gaze,
Faun's gone.
This seems to be a clear proof that Ophelia dreamed of the expedition,
to deal more easily with her sad life.
But if we go back, we see how del Toro complicates
that scene by Vidal drank a strong dose of sleeping medication.
Elsewhere, drug-induced hallucinations are used to explain
why people see supernatural things, but in Faun's labyrinth it is the other way around.
Del Toro uses this means to question what Vidal sees.
Here and elsewhere, the film refuses to obey our desire
after an all-explaining denouement.
Obviously, disobedience is the main theme in this film.
Why didn't you listen to me?
To obey, to obey without question
is something that only people like you are capable of, Captain.
While in many other fairy tales disobedience is used to start the story,
here, disobedience is displayed as a fundamental and important value.
We see the disobedience of the rebels who want to liberate Spain
from the crack of fascism.
Disobedience Mercedes, which works with the rebels
and, of course, the disobedience of Ophelia, which challenges and neglects commands
your mother, captain, and fauna.
But the most impressive disobedience is that depicted in the very context of the film.
And here are del Tor's references to the word.
It accomplishes many interpretations of what we see that undermines authoritative characters
Vidala and generally fascists and interacting links,
whose tone is purely our choice.
Take all those links at Fauna's headquarters.
We see a giant who enjoys eating a baby
and other mythologies like Krampuse
or references to the Greek titan Kronos, who has eaten his children,
to prevent young people from taking their place, just like fascism in Spain.
I should also mention that Kronos is the name of the first del Toro film.
It's one thing that connects him with his work.
The table refers to the previous scene and Fauna puts it in the same position as Vidala,
who then kills the child.
Pile of shoes refers to Ophelia's red shoes,
which gets at a later stage of the film and are themselves a reference
the Wizard of Oz and the 1948 film by Powell and Pressburger.
We can also interpret it as a reference to piles of clothing
the Nazi concentration camps and the scene itself act as a metaphor
for the way we beauty fairy tales us
can charm and force us to think in a way
which may not be in our interest.
Here you have an extensive network of commands that interfere with other parts of the movie
but also beyond.
The viewer is supposed to follow this as he sees fit.
Del Toro intertwines these links with camera and editing
thus moving the story forward.
If you're watching his movies, you can't deny it.
The purpose of the vidal was, as well as the purpose of all authoritarian regimes
or patriarchal moralistic fairy tales, limit the number and kind of stories
which can be narrated and supported by facts or events
to just one story.
The only way is to disobey.
The old fairy tales had a closed story that ended in one word: the end.
Del Toro's genius is to use a stereotypical genre
and disobeying our expectations of how the story was to develop and end.
The rebels will capture and kill Vidal, but Spain will remain in control
authoritarian dictatorship for 30 years.
Ophelia is murdered but completes her expedition
and return to the underground kingdom.
You can perceive it as a poetic end to a sad story
as a happy ending of the fairy tale or as Ophelia's last choice in the story
who wants to talk about himself.
Of course, they do not have to choose.
There could be no separate story on it.
Because even when she returned to the world of magic,
she left references from the times she walked among us for you
who know where to find them.